but I believe the answer is yes I
believe India can and will prevent super
power over the next three to four
decades what is important is leadership
leadership both the private and public
sectors of the venture and my
perspective obviously is one of
leadership the exactly search terms that
place leaders around the globe and if
you have the right environment to foster
leadership and look at this right from
the school all the way through initial
campus recruitment and then training and
management in relation to corporations
and the public sector then you have
Stephen Amell leaders you have going to
happen the matter to you move forward in
this country will definitely then I'm
gonna supervise